wie geil finden sie armin laschet
und inga die geisel musste ihn
richtig geil
[Musik]
armin laschet hat starke freunde
und er hat freunde
wie sind sie denn freund von armin
laschet geworden was sowie bei
schwarzenegger sie haben so lange
behauptet bis selbst erst geglaubt ja
er konnte gar nicht mehr anders ja wer
will da nein sagen ich habe gesagt armin
ab heute bist du mein freund und dann
guckte er
ist mein freund und da war das klar zu
halten sind wir freunde da ist hat dinge
rizzi h das ist der frage wie viel hallo
ist macht wahlkampf für armin laschet
haben wir nichts besseres zu tun im
moment werden sie in willen nein warum
nicht weil ich generell die cdu nicht
viel aber ich könnte ihnen ein anreiz
setzen ja sie haben gelacht wird wählen
im september ist er weg aus nrw
das ist ein gutes ist nun die erste
stimme gewonnen für armin laschet über
unsere ministerpräsident und über mein
freund wird nicht gelästert das sage ich
dir du armin laschet ist der beste java
nahm ihn ist ein wirklicher das muss man
sagen brückenbauer ja nun mit dem rücken
lockdown hat zwar nicht so geklappt aber
ja ich mache wahlkampf für armin machen
also sie sind für laschet oder kann man
so sie mehr will er aber ich meine der
sie haben ihn noch unter kontrolle oder
ein jeder war wählt bei uns das was er
für richtig hält wir haben unabhängige
meinungsbildung für wein aber nur
samstag sie machen wahlkampf für
migration das dürfen sie oft schon
wählen ja klar wen finden sie besser
armin laschet oder ralf müller
also beide haben potenzial armin ganz
klar zum kanzler und ralf möller war
auch mal angedacht angedacht als
ministerpräsident das heißt wenn lastet
noch handy name laschet nach berlin geht
als kanzler stehe ich zur verfügung als
ministerpräsident aber ich muss sagen
sie können sich dann auch unter die neue
rheinbrücke bei leverkusen stellen und
die einfach so halten blasen wir den
bizeps einmal auf
genau für das team laschet wie geil
finden sie ja mit lasse
so konnte wiegard
richtigkeit warum findet sogar sehr
sympatisch ist und weil ja auch kurios
wir machen so ich verstehe den ausweis
damit du wählen kann es bei der nächsten
wahl ja so machen wir müssen noch einmal
sagen dass wir das senden dürfen
[Gelächter]
zwar versuchen sie das denn natürlich
war armin laschet ich es lieber jogi löw
eine schlaftablette und immer weiter so
da gucken sie doch mal an her
wahrscheinlich wie gepflegte
interessanter man zweifelsohne aber er
redet maßstab 221
redet und redet und sitzt nicht zum und
er steht dafür weiter so wie angela
merkel also der gleiche lohn noch mal
fünf jahre zurückreicht für nrw ist ein
guter minister für nrw armin laschet für
nrw reicht reicht sie wählen lassen ich
sagte ihnen nahe am ende des tages die
hübsche sie wählen lautet aller fragen
ich werde nur spd ja gut da sind sie ja
auch aussterbende art
damit ist alles klar armin laschet wird
kanzler ralf müller wird
ministerpräsident und ich werde den
muskelkater meines lebens habe
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt haye